bonjour et bienvenue pour cette science
consacrée aujourd'hui à 1,6 à 8 033 9 8
800 ha pardon pardon mais eux c'est
censé être quoi ça c'est la divine
proportions voyons le nombre d'or celui
qui expliquerait tout de la spirale des
gigantesques galaxie à cette vie
microscopique foraminifères en passant
par inutiles les pommes de pin et nos
propres proportions corporelles
si on en croit la sagesse populaire les
livres de maths et surtout les fonds
d'écran microsoft le nombre d'or serait
partout dans la nature
quoi de plus merveilleux qu'une belle
spirale quoi de plus harmonieux que
toutes ses courbes buzz entrelacés son
omniprésence dans la nature témoigne de
l'harmonie qui règne dans notre monde du
soin apporté par thèmes nature à la
conception de notre bel univers dame
nature était sérieuse tu veux dire dame
nature comme cette dame nature l'a jeté
à porter ton petit cadeau oui et moi
mais nous votons pas que je m'emballe un
peu trop c'est ça je crois que tu as
deviné
et puis avant de nous affirmer que le
nombre d'or est présent partout tu
pourrais commencer par nous dire d'où il
sort le nombre dormant
ah bah ça c'est très simple le nombre
d'or c'est fini c'est le ratio de deux
valeurs a et b tel que a + b / à égal à
surveiller quelle fille parce que tu dis
n'a aucun sens c'est pourtant très
simples en gros tu as un segment qui le
coupe en deux morceaux a et b mais pas
au milieu de telle sorte que la longueur
totale a + b / la longueur du plus grand
segment up soit égal à la valeur que tu
obtiens en divisant les deux segments a
et b entre a et à 17h frisbee et tara
quoi c'est ça le nombre d'or un bête
ratio une division ça a l'air vachement
arbitraire comme truc parce que ça m'est
complètement le nombre d'or est un outil
mathématique créé avant tout par les
matins pour les matins et le nombre d'or
c'est aussi la seule solution à
l'équation x carré - x - un égal 0
tant la thermo carrés à terme simple une
équation égal à zéro tu veux dire que le
nombre dans en fait c'est la solution
d'une équation du second degré j'ai
ressenti un grand bouleversement
comme si des millions de voix avait
soudainement hurlaient de terreur
ça suffit la mieux jouer sur la peur des
maths c'est fou quand même dit que vous
n'aimez pas aux kings et tout le monde
le prend pour un idiot
tandis que vous comprenez rien aux
mettent soudainement vous passer pour un
héros
pardon de madame je leur ferai plus
merci oui et la solution de cette
équation c'est un plus racine de 5 sur
deux soit environ 1,6 en 2008 et des
poussières soit fille le fameux nombre
d'or bombe allait pas bien jolie cette
divine proportions arbitraires à souhait
et c'est même pas un nombre entier
alors qu'est ce qu'il a de particulier
ce ratio en or massif pour mériter tous
ces honneurs sait que de par sa
définition il possède des propriétés
géométriques qui facilite la
répétabilité motif même à des échelles
de tailles différentes
si on a un segment et qu on le divise
par un bien 1618 et des brouettes on
obtient deux plus petits segment est en
recommençant la division par 1,618 sur
le plus grand des deux on obtient deux
nouveaux segments encore plus petits
dont le plus grand toujours conformes
nombre d'or peut à nouveau être / 1,618
et ainsi de suite
en appliquant cette recette
mathématiques sur un rectangle on
obtient des rectangles qui s'imbriquent
les uns dans les autres
la longueur des arts formant la largeur
des autres et empereur la terre et l'adc
rectangle et en arrondissant un petit
peu les angles on obtient une belle
spirale les propriétés du nombre d'or
permettent de répéter la construction de
formes géométriques d'une même
architecture
mais à des échelles différentes et c'est
très pratique pour la croissance de
certains êtres vivants ou déformée
similaire de différentes tailles peuvent
ainsi s'imbriquent les unes dans les
autres
de manière précise d'un point de vue
strictement théorique on comprendrait
aisément que l'apparition de formes
vivantes tendant à se structurer autour
des proportions d'or soit favorisé lors
de la sélection naturelle
il suffit en effet de ne construire
qu'une seule fois un élément donné puis
d'un seul gène commandant de répéter la
construction de cet élément à différents
stades de la croissance pour obtenir un
être vivant tout entier pas besoin
d'avoir un plan détaillé pour assembler
chacune des parties de notre corps
faites-en un morceau une fois et
recommencer autant de fois qu'il le faut
et le tour est joué
c'est exactement comme une courbe dite
fractale tout part d'une idée très
simple vous prenez un segment vous
faites un triangle au milieu du segment
puis vous recommencez le
ration sur chaque phase du triangle
ainsi obtenu puis vous recommencez
encore une fois sur les triangles ainsi
formé etc etc etc
et alors fini par apparaître quelque
chose qui n'est plus une droite mais bel
et bien une structure complexe une
courbe dite fractale pourtant toute
cette complexité n'est que le fruit de
la réitération de la même opération
fondamentalement très simple plusieurs
fois d'affilée il ne serait pas étonnant
que les êtres vivants fonctionnement
d'une telle manière connaissent un grand
succès évolutif quelle chance laisserait
un organisme dont l'adn n'aurez qu'à
dire le feu soit une fois et puis il
recommence jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise
d'arrêter à un autre dont l'adn devrait
programmer la forme de chaque centimètre
carré de son anatomie
il faut bien admettre que le premier
aurait un avantage singulier sur le
seconde dans une fractale les motifs
sont imbriqués les uns dans les autres
et se répètent à l'infini
l'imbrication des structures les unes
dans les autres que dans une courbe
fractales est elle même très avantageuse
du point de vue évolutif car elle permet
de mettre un maximum de structures dans
un minimum de place
cela permet de produire plus de
défendant quand ladite structure est
impliqué dans la reproduction ou bien de
stocker plus de nourriture dans un
minimum d'espacé
le recours au nombre d'or serait donc
économique avec peu de gêne il
optimiserait l'espace et évitera le
gâchis de place mais mais mais mais quoi
on parle de biologie là il ya toujours
un mais mais non il n'y a pas de lait
qui tiennent aussi le forcément un mec
très bon évidemment ça n'est applicable
qu'à les structures répétable la divine
proportions ne s'applique pas au corps
humain par exemple il n'y a pas de
raison pour que les proportions humaines
suivre particulièrement le nombre d'or
puisque sa croissance n'a rien à voir
avec une répétition du même élément en
une version plus grande ou plus petit et
le bébé ce n'est pas un adulte modèles
réduits il a ses propres proportions et
l'adulte ne lui ressemble pas vraiment
tout juste peut-on chercher le nombre
d'or dans certaines parties qui se
construisent comme une répétition
d'éléments comme les phalanges mais même
là il faut bien admettre que c'est pas
gagné et puis et puis en fait le nombre
doit on le trouve presque nulle part le
pain et le tournesol
ok on y voit une suite de fibonacci et
qui d'ailleurs ne donne qu'une
approximation du nombre d'or et pour le
reste des millions d'espèces qui peut
plus la terre est tout les spirales ne
sont pas dehors ni de fibonacci dallaire
tous les goûts sont dans la nature
le nautile les ammonites les galaxies ça
ne l'est pas tant que ça avec le nombre
d'or finalement une approximation du
nombre
on n'est présente que j'ai très peu
d'espèces et de structures en général
c'est juste qu'on bloque un peu trop sur
celle où ça marche et qu'on passe à côté
de l'immense majorité de celles dont les
proportions de correspondent par
ailleurs mais qui le vivent pourtant
très bien nous y compris
ce qui nous amène au grand théorème du
nombre d'or la deuxième loi la plus
puissante de l'univers après la loi de
murphy
ouvrez bien grand vos oreilles le nombre
d'or quand on le cherche
on le trouve tout base de données
contenant des nombres et trituré
suffisamment longtemps à la recherche du
nombre-d'or finira par vous donner un
nombre d'heures le nombre d'or fait
partie de ce genre d'objets
scientifiques à qui on fait dire bien
plus de choses qui n'en est capable
parler de divine proportion s'est
légèrement exagéré notre attrait pour la
divine proportion reflète notre envie de
comprendre notre monde
elle est l'héritage des grands savants
du 19e siècle qui cherchait à tout
comprendre au travers des mathématiques
c'est en quelque sorte d'incarnation de
ce vieux rêve des physiciens d'antan qui
pensaient pouvoir un jour mettre la
nature tout entière en équation attend
là pourquoi il y aurait que les
physiciens qui auraient envie de mettre
la nature en équation après tout
comprendre les rouages mathématiques des
êtres vivants et de leur évolution ça
aiderait surtout les biologistes non oui
c'est certain mais les biologistes ça
fait très longtemps qu'ils ont compris
que l'évolution des espèces se torcher
avec les maths voyant sur les huit
longueurs
ah non non non non il n'y a pas un mot
trop et êtres vivants se contrefiche des
lois ils n'ont aucune loi ils sont au
dessus des lois
la mode coop qui dit qu'elle est
magnifique on tendance à grandir au
cours de la révolution la loi de bergman
qui stipule que les espèces vivant près
des pôles sont plus trapu que leurs
homologues des pechos on s'assoit dessus
voyons il est impossible de survivre
dans le vide spatial est un des grades
font ça très bien survivre dans un bagne
mercure vous
plus difficile la loi de la gravité vous
pensez réellement que la loi de la
gravité est inviolable
je me gausse toute cette naïveté c'est
si mignons et celui-là il a pourtant
bien mais elle nous est libre pensez
vraiment qu'ils auraient dû s'effondrer
sur lui même en matière de biologie
il n'y a qu'une seule règle l'exception
aucune loi ne s'applique à la totalité
du vivant impossible n'est pas
biologique
plus fort encore les travaux du regretté
délit drop sur les coquilles de
mollusques ont montré qu'avec trois
paramètres simple l'enrôlement la
hauteur du tour de spirale et la forme
de l'ouverture de la coquille il était
possible de recréer toutes les formes de
co qui connaît aussi bien actuelle que
fossiles
en fait il a découvert bien plus que
cela il s'est rendu compte que malgré
l'infinité de formes possibles
moins d'un quart d'entre elles seulement
ont un jour existé toutes époques
confondues fossiles inclus
la plus grande partie des formes de coty
possible n'existe pas et n'ont jamais
existé
la nature ne fait pas seulement des
choses impossibles elle se permet aussi
parfois le luxe de ne pas faire
certaines choses
pourtant très facile quand on nous dit
que le vivant ça c'est sûr les règles
pourtant ça n'a pas découragé alan
turing si ça tu connais pas le célèbre
génie des mathématiques héros du film
imitation game sharing filtering s'il y
en avait bien un pour réussir avec le
niveau en équation c'était lui dans un
article de 1952 son premier et dernier
sur le sujet turing formalise un modèle
d'une incroyable simplicité et pouvant
rendre compte de la tout aussi
incroyable complexité des motifs
observables sur le pelage des mammifères
tâche ses rayons notamment mais qui
s'applique aussi sur la répartition des
écailles des pommes de pins et des
ananas ou bien encore sur les motifs des
ailes des papillons
le modèle de turing est une réaction
chimique théorie prenons deux composés
chimiques a et b quant à elles
fabriquées par des cellules par exemple
à stimule sa propre fabrication les
seagulls alentours à se répand jusque là
rien d'anormal à stimule aussi la
fabrication de baies mais contrairement
à à b n'est pas un stimulant
c'est à régulateur b empêche la
fabrication de plus de à elle et à se
tirer une balle dans le pied pour ainsi
dire car ils sont nombreux et stimuler
la formation de plus de b alors que
va-t-il se passer
ben là comme ça si l'un stimule
l'autre et que l'autre le réguler je
dirais que les deux vont finir par
s'équilibrer et oui et non en fait ils
vont bien s'équilibrer mais ce serait un
équilibre dynamique regarde dans un
premier temps à s'est répandue car il se
stimulent lui même mais il simule aussi
la fabrication de baies arrive donc un
moment où b va devenir à son tour très
abondant trop abondants ah oui bva
réguler à mais au final 100 ha pour le
stimuler à déficit hors baie va finir
par s'installer jusqu'à atteindre une
centaine équilibre la haye trop
abondants il ne peut pas régressé plus
car ils s'auto stimule et ici b ne peut
plus réguler a davantage car c'est à qui
le stimule maintenant répéter
l'opération à plus grande échelle comme
ça non encore plus grande histoire
massa lors des rayures vertes et rouges
et oui et remplace l'emplacement de à
part une protéine disons de la mélanine
le pigment de la peau et des poils et
celui de baie par une autre protéine
incolore et on obtient un zèbre
les expériences réalisées par des
chimistes français spécialiste des
structures de turing notamment patrick
de kepper et son équipe ainsi que des
modélisations informatiques ont démontré
qu'en jouant sur les facteurs de ce
modèle très simple il est possible de
réaliser des structures de turing
pouvant rendre compte de la forme des
tâches des guépards des girafes des
jaguar ou bien même de la forme des
coraux des motifs des coquillages et de
bien d'autres choses
maintenant tu peux mettre n'importe quoi
la place 2e année de bep par exemple
apps directement un dieu la formation
les écales d'une pomme de pain et c'est
ça le génial modèle de turing quelle
puissance quelle simplicité il prévoit
même que les dimensions de la surface
sur laquelle ont lieu ce type de
réactions chimiques vont avoir une
influence sur la forme des structures
observable par exemple le modèle prédit
que sur des surfaces plus grandes les
rayons vont avoir tendance à devenir des
tâches exactement ce qui se passe entre
la clé le corps du guépard
c'est magique non mieux que ça c'est
mathématique
mais alors ça veut dire que c'est
certainement le même mécanisme qui
commande la formation des rayons des
zèbres et des tâches de guépard même si
ces deux motifs sont très différents je
souhaite une possibilité puisque
envisageable il suffirait pour cela que
le facteur qui commande la formation des
motifs apparaissent très tôt chez le
zèbre quand il est encore
petit embryon mais bien plus tard chez
le départ quand sa surface de peau est
plus grande
c'est même plus fort que ça on a pu
calculer que étant donné la largeur des
rayures des zèbres à l'âge adulte le
facteur commandant l'apparition des
rayures devait apparaître très tôt
durant le développement du petit zèbre
dès le 20e jours après la fécondation
sur un embryon très pudique et le zèbre
début rochelle qui possède de larges
rayures
elles sont ensuite plus étroites ch et 2
0 des montagnes et celui de grévy
checchi l'apparition du facteur
commandant les rayures a été estimé à
l'âge de 28 et 35 jours respectivement
sur des embryons proportionnellement
bien plus grand et c'est exactement ce
qu'on observe sur les embryons de ces
animaux se draguent un tel pouvoir
prédictif et il fait pas tout il est
même possible de créer une réaction au
sian tu si a continué de décroître à
cause de b alors bay finira par
décroître aussi parce que c'est à qui le
stimule et dès lors à pourra recommencer
à s'auto stimuler comme avant reprenant
le dessus sur b jusqu'à ce que b soit de
nouveau en quantité trop importante et
réguler de nouveau à et ainsi de suite
tant qu'il y a de quoi fabriquer du hae
d'ubs et ça ne s'arrête jamais et
félicitations vous venez de créer une
horloge biologique une pardon chic et
tout ça uniquement à partir d'éléments
chimiques inerte qu'on ne fait que
mélanger tout le reste les structures de
turing et les oscillations se forme
juste naturellement spontanément quand
les réactifs se rencontrent grâce à de
telles situations il devient très facile
de mesurer le temps et surtout de
commander un organisme de répéter une
opération de façon cyclique
à chaque fois que la quantité de à
devient la plus importante mon organisme
rajoute un triangle sur chaque segment
de droite ou bien il rajoute une
ramification à cette feuille de fougères
par exemple qu'en combinant ainsi les
fractales avec le modèle de turing c'est
tout un univers de possibilités
morphologiques qui saura nous et comme
tout cela fonctionnerait de façon
excessivement simple il n'y a pas de
raison que la sélection naturelle n'en
ai pas voulu ça ne veut pas dire que
cette explication est la bonne ou que ce
mécanisme soit le seul havre est dans la
nature
non il ne s'agit pas de vérité mais
c'est quand même un modèle vachement
élégant et raffiné
il faut toutefois nuancer notre
enthousiasme même si ce modèle s'avérait
vrai dans le cadre des motifs décrit ici
et qui reste somme toute assez limitées
il faut bien l'admettre pour ce qui est
de la mise en équation total de la vie
dans son ensemble de son écologie et de
son évolution
c'est pas demain la veille ah c'est tout
de même un pas en avant et est chercheur
s'autorise chedjou europe puis ça
au sérieux la possibilité de prédire à
quoi ressembleront les mondes du futur
en conclusion le modèle de turing offre
une nouvelle perspective sur l'évolution
des structures complexes que les
recherches au nombre d'ordres l'avait
fait qu'effleurer
car trop limité cantonné que dis-je
borné à l'étude de ce seul et unique
ratio le modèle de turing plus
facilement généralisable explique bien
mieux comment de la simplicité peut
naître une grande complexité turing ne
résout pas seulement le mystère des
rayures du zèbre des taches de léopard
ou des feuilles de fougères il démontre
que d'un seul type de phénomène chimique
simple peut découler une grande
complexité morphologiques aventure et on
pensait que chacune des tâches vidéo par
devait avoir sa propre ligne de commande
adn chacune indiquant individuellement à
chaque cellules de la peau de l'animal
où quand et comment se crée fait
pigments afin de créer de l'exacte
patron de la tâche qu'il fallait
imaginer l' usine à gaz
maintenant grâce à turing on sait qu'un
tout petit nombre de gènes suffisent
deux gènes en fait
hanotaux stimulateur et un régulateur
c'est tout la physique et la chimie font
le reste
turing nous éclaire sur l'origine et le
fonctionnement de la vie en général
grâce à lui nous savons désormais qu'à
partir de composés chimiques inerte
n'est une structure en équilibre
dynamique presque vivante
si l'un de vos sources y serez hausse à
l'évocation de cette drôle d'idée
alors c'est qu'il faut qu'on vous
éclaire avec une petite analogie est
justement parlons est clair avec des
chocolats nom du café non plus les
éclairer leurs ramifications complexes
leur déploiement harmonieux et leur
puissance prodigieuse sont l'oeuvre de
phénomènes physiques très simple il ne
serait pas étonnant qu'avec votre double
décimètre en mesurant cette arborescence
lumineuse dans tous les sens vous ne
finissez pas à paris découvrir une
divine par an pendant une olympique
proportions pourtant dans cette forme
aussi fascinante et complexe qu'elle
soit est issu d'un simple phénomène
électrique du plus du moins qui rentrent
en contact et c'est tout ce phénomène
est parfaitement compris depuis très
longtemps déjà
le monde est plein d'autres exemples de
processus apparemment très complexe qui
pourtant ont une origine
physico-chimiques fondamentalement très
simple et ce qu'est la nature in usa
appris c'est que la vie pourrait bien
être de ceux là
merci à tous la complexité qui apparaît
tout seul
ouaip enfin s'est produit une explosion
dans une imprimerie qui a écrit
l'intégrale de victor hugo non plus en
fait c'est qui la fesci bien notre
système solaire est issu de la
condensation des nuages de matière ni de
l'explosion d'une supernova la création
les gaspille des particules a ensuite
conduit à l'apparition de la terre à
laquelle la vie est apparue et l'être
humain a évolué et puis victor hugo
vinay donc dans un sens si ces cas une
explosion qui a répondu à l'écriture des
romans du ctos rigaud message esprit
tête milliards d'aller avec le temps
même l'impossible devient inévitable